all right welcome back everybody so this
lecture we're going to be talking a
little bit more about integral laws for
vector fields next week there will be no
class it's Thanksgiving week so just
have a like holiday and the week after
Thanksgiving will be the last week of
classes so you'll have the final exam
handed out on Wednesday and due Friday
the week after Thanksgiving and there
will be three final lectures during that
week
okay so we'll kind of wrap up vector
fields and vector calculus and we might
talk a little bit more about linear
algebra inner products vector spaces
that kind of thing so kind of just tying
up all the loose ends and getting ready
for the next quarter on partial
differential equations how many of you
have had a chance to look through this
week's homework yet okay are there any
questions on anything in the homework at
this point yeah yeah when I say prove I
just mean show yeah any other questions
about the homework yeah okay cool so
today we're going to talk about Stokes's
theorem okay so we talked about Gauss's
divergence theorem already which was
super powerful Gauss's theorem allowed
us to write surface integrals of flux
through a surface as volume integrals of
the divergence in the volume okay that
was Gauss's theorem today we're gonna be
talking about Stokes's theorem which is
I think probably the most powerful of
all of these vector calculus identities
so Stokes's theorem and there's a lot of
really really really cool
outcomes of Stokes's theorem that we're
going to talk about today so lots of
ramifications that we can derive from
from Stokes's theorem again I'm going to
basically assume that you
no lots of vector calculus you know how
to integrate functions and long paths
you know how to integrate surfaces and
volumes and we're gonna be talking about
the high level kind of theorems that
relate these surface integrals to volume
integrals and line integrals to surface
integrals and things like that
okay that's what these really are so
Stokes's theorem essentially says that
if I have some surface let's call the
surface s and if I have some boundary to
this surface
so we're gonna denote boundaries by
partial s this is just the math notation
for boundary then the integral around
this surface of some vector field is
equal to the surface integral of the
curl of that vector field so let me
write this down and then we'll talk
about what each each term means so the
integral around the boundary of s this
is kind of a closed contour integral if
you like of my vector field F dotted
with some little vector this is a vector
D s is equal to the surface integral
over the entire surface s of the curl of
F times some some area term okay yes
okay so let's talk about what this means
again I'm not going to prove this I'm
going to sketch kind of why this is true
but you know for a proof you should see
like a vector calculus book the idea is
that if I have some vector field
remember this is like a vector field
might be the flow field in the ocean or
it might be you know I maybe I have some
point charges or I have a transformer
that I'm energizing and it's creating
some electromagnetic field that's also a
vector field and so I have arrows at
every point in space for my vector field
F and if I integrate that vector field
along the surface so I figure out how
much of that vector field is pointing in
the direction of this boundary and I
integrate around the entire boundary
that's exactly equal to the integral of
the area of the whole surface of the
curl of my vector field okay so this is
an area just this is an integral just
around the surface of F dotted with this
surface vector and that contour integral
is equal to this two-dimensional surface
integral of the curl of my vector field
okay so let's draw a picture to see kind
of why this makes sense one way that I
like to think about this and this is
kind of the most common picture I've
seen before is let's say we take our
surface s and we chop it up into a bunch
of really small boxes okay so I'm gonna
just draw a bunch of I mean they're not
ridiculously small but they're gonna be
kind of small small boxes okay now
remember if I had a vector field F that
had some positive divergence maybe
divergence equals one what did that look
like locally what did the vector field
with a positive divergence look like all
the arrows were kind of starbursting out
from the center right so this was kind
of like
era is just going out right what did a
vector field with a positive curl look
like things rotating things were
spinning around right so this looked
like you know I had some some rotation
right like if I drop something in this
vector field it would rotate around they
wouldn't just flee from the origin it
would rotate around the origin so if I
compute the curl kind of at each of
these imagine I made these boxes really
really really really really small
you know teeny tiny boxes then if I
computed the curl in these boxes I would
basically be measuring how much in the
vector field does this locally I would
be measuring how much locally the vector
field rotates versus spreads okay and so
I can draw that for all of these little
boxes and in this direction it looks
like this and in this direction it looks
like this and so on and so forth I'm
gonna try to draw a few of them so we
get the picture across okay so I draw
with the curl this is essentially curl
of F at that point that's kind of a
pictorial view of what curl at this
point looks like and so what happens if
I add all of these curls up so what
happens is most of these arrows cancel
out okay so the vector field you know
the curl portion of this box and this
box have equal and opposite components
on that on that interface and they have
equal and opposite components on this
interface and this interface and every
every interior line the curl from the
right box cancels the curl from the left
box and the curl from the top box
cancels the curl from the bottom box
right my arrows are pointing to the
right and to the left and if I integrate
over these if I integrate over this path
plus the integral over this path plus
the integral over this path
get a bunch of equal and opposite paths
that cancel out okay so this integral of
my whole volume of the curl of F D s
every single interior black line cancels
out and all I have left is this contour
integral of these surface boundaries the
only pieces that don't have equal and
opposite contributions are these arrows
that are on the outside all of these
arrows are not canceled and so what I
get is the integral around the boundary
of F dotted with that tangent surface
vector okay okay there are probably
questions about why this is true any
questions at this point
so I think something that would help a
little bit is to say that this curl
really does equal so the curl of F at a
point the curl of F at some point X is
equal to the contour integral let's say
I have this point X if I did a contour
integral around that point some contour
C and it was really really really really
small contour of f dot d s then that
equals the curl at that point ok this is
a property you can actually derive this
this property that the curl of my vector
field at that point X is essentially
equal to this contour integral as I make
that contour smaller and smaller and
smaller around my point X ok so
integrating up all of the curls at every
point in this boundary is like adding up
all of these little contour integrals
these little square contour integrals
but all of the interior square contour
integrals cancel out right the up and
the down components cancel the left and
the right components cancel and all
that's left are the parts that don't
have an equal and opposite on the
surface ok and so this is essentially
the pictorial reason why we have Stokes
theorem ok it's not a proof
but it's kind of a geometric idea for
why this is true
okay but Stokes theorem is extremely
useful if you like you can just take
this identity for granted this is a
fundamental mathematical truth it can be
proved that if I wanted to take the
integral around the boundary of a
surface that would equal the surface
integral of the curl of that vector
field inside the surface okay so this is
starting to look a lot like Gauss's
theorem right I had some integral on a
lower dimensional surface and that tells
me about something about the you know
the kind of volume or area integral
inside that surface that can enclosed
integral so it turns out actually if you
eventually learn about like Tenzer
calculus and tensor math the divergence
theorem Gauss's divergence theorem is
actually just a special case of Stokes's
theorem it's really hard to see why
that's true without a lot more math but
it is true that Stokes's theorem kind of
is the master of vector calculus theorem
that contains Gauss's theorem Green's
theorem and Stokes's theorem and the
Russian guy's name was Oscar a grad
scheme Ostra grad ski also invented the
divergence theorem okay so a special
case of Stokes's theorem this also
applies to higher dimensions than just
three dimensions but usually we're going
to be thinking about this in 2d or 3d
okay third for this class and so in 2d
we have greens theorem
and green serum is pretty pretty similar
I mean it's exactly the same thing as
Stokes there I'm just applied in to you
so let's say I have my vector field F
equals f1 and f2 so this is the
component in the X direction and f2 is
the component in the Y Direction these
are scalar functions this is a vector
function then what we have is remember
we have this surface F and a boundary
partial s so the integral around the
surface of f dot d s so in 2d this is
the same thing as the integral around
the boundary of the surface of f1 DX
plus f2 dy ok so if I want to just take
my vector function f and I want to
integrate it around this surface dotting
it into the tangent at each point
that's this integral here integral
around the surface of f1 DX plus f2 dy
then that equals the surface integral of
the curl of this vector field right okay
so what's the curl of my vector field F
how do I do
what's curl of s what direction does the
curl point in
sorry Z right it points out of the board
right because my vector field has an X
component and a y component so if I curl
that vector field it has to point out of
the board in the Z direction and what's
the magnitude of that out of the board
Direction partial f1 partial Y minus
partial F to partial X okay so this is
minus partial f1 partial Y sorry plus
minus partial F to partial X and that's
all in the K direction all right in the
DZ direction if you like so this equals
my surface integral of partial f2
I think I messed up the sign sorry
partial F to partial X minus partial f1
partial Y integrated around the entire
surface and I have a DX and a dy a
double integral DX dy right I'm
integrating over this entire surface now
every interior point I'm going to add up
the curl of the vector field at that
point times the little area of that
rectangle and that's how I can relate
the integral around the curve to the
integral of the curl inside the surface
so this is just kind of in 2d if we
actually wrote down the components of
our vector field the x and y components
we can write it down explicitly this is
Stokes theorem in 2d ok and so if you
had some if I gave you a function f1 and
f2 you could actually compute these
integrals so let's do an example where
we where we start doing this okay so
there's one nice implication about
there's I think two or three really
direct uses for Stokes theorem and I'm
going to try to get through all of them
today so the first use of Stokes's
theorem let's say the first use is
computing the area okay so I can
actually compute the area inside of a
surface by integrating around the
surface if I choose my vector field
carefully okay
so let's say that the area of s what is
the area of s equal how do i compute the
area of my surface s
I mean I would integrate over my area 1
times DX DUI right if I wanted to find
the area of my surface I would literally
just integrate DX dy over that surface
and I would get the area of s okay now
I'm gonna go backwards a little bit I'm
gonna say let my vector field F equal
minus y and X so I'm choosing this
vector field I have the choice videos
I'm choosing this vector field so that
it has a curl equal to positive 2 so
curl of F equals partial dis partial X
minus partial this partial Y which is
positive 2 okay so I can write this
integral as 1/2 surface integral of 2 DX
dy if I want and remember I can take my
Stokes's theorem and say that my surface
integral of the curl of a my vector
field is equal to the contour integral
of my vector field dotted in the normal
direction so this equals 1/2 of my
contour integral of F dotted in the S
direction
so let's talk about how we got to this
step so this is pretty straightforward
the area of s is just the integral of 1
over that area that's equal to one-half
of the integral of 2 over that area
right no problem two is the curl of my
vector field okay and we know that the
the surface integral of the curl of my
vector field DX dy is equal to the
contour integral of my vector field dot
d s right this is just Stokes's theorem
the the surface integral of the curl of
my vector field is equal to the contour
integral of my vector field dot d s so I
just chose this vector field arbitrarily
because it has really nice properties
that its curl is a constant so I can use
it to get this area ok and so now I
finally have that this is 1/2 integral
over this boundary of s of F dotted with
D s so that's minus y DX plus X dy this
is my F dot d s minus y in the DX
direction and X in the DUI direction so
let's just so the first part the the key
here is that the area of s can be
written as 1/2 of a contour integral
around the surface of X dy minus y DX
this is kind of cool if I have any
arbitrary area s you give me some area
if I simply take this special vector
field this vector field that has curl 2
and I integrate that vector field around
the contour bounding s that will always
give me the area inside
of s so this is a way of computing the
area of a nasty shape without actually
doing a double integral if this is a
single integral okay just a path
integral around the boundary gives me
the area inside that's pretty cool
sorry any okay questions about this yeah
yeah so x and y literally are you know
coordinates in in this vector space and
so what we what I would have to tell you
is how can i parameterize this boundary
i need to give you a parameterization of
this boundary in terms of x and y so
that you can then make that integral so
let's do an example this will make a lot
of sense when we do an example and it's
kind of a cool example unfortunately all
of these integral examples the math gets
a little hairy at the end but the basic
idea is still pretty cool so we're going
to find the area inside of a really
really important geometric object called
a hypo cycloid okay does anyone know
what a hypo cycloid looks like hypo
cycloids are super cool you should
google them I did they're awesome okay
let's use a color here so the idea of a
hypo cycloid is that it's kind of this
funny-looking shape like this kind of
this star shape pattern okay and I want
to know the area inside of this hypo
cycloid now this is a pretty nasty
double integral if you actually do this
using you know integral over x and y DX
dy
a real pain and so this is a great
example of using Stokes's theorem so
what I'm going to do is integrate my
nice special curl equals two vector
field around the boundary of this type
of cycloid and it's going to tell me
what the area inside has to be by
Stokes's theorem hypo cycloids how many
of you play with spiral graphs when
you're kids yeah so spiral graphs are
awesome hypo cycloids are what you get
from spiral graphs basically if you take
like a circle and you have another
circle that's moving inside of it and
you have a little hole where you can
drop your pen and as you rotate this
thing around this circle is spinning
inside the big circle and it traces out
I can't really do it but it traces out
this hypo cycloid okay and if you get
the radius of this circle with respect
to this circle at different ratios of
the radius you get like more sides to
the starfish you might get five or six
or seven or ten or whatever however many
sides of the starfish they have great
properties they're not just kids toys
these hypo cycloids
are also used believe it or not these
are used in image compression they're
used for if I have a satellite image of
your license plate and it's really
blurry and I only can pick out a file a
few pixels there are transformations
like the fast Fourier transform but that
use hypo cycloids that allow me to fill
in what your license plate has to be
based on the information I get okay this
is something I'll tell you all about in
any 565 but hypo cycloids are super cool
so let's find the area of this type of
cycle and using Stokes's theorem okay
let's not do it in red okay so the hypo
cycloid is a surface that's defined by
the following equation X to the 2/3 plus
y to the 2/3 equals some a to the 2/3
you can think of a is the radius of this
thing kind of okay so this is the point
a zero
this is the point zero a and so on so a
is the scale factor of how big this hypo
cycloid is the radius if you like I can
change this hypo cycloid by changing
this power I could have two-fifths and
then I would have more weird curves if I
had 2/7 then I would have seven faces
things like that try a different hypo
cycloids and to your question earlier
what we're going to do is we're going to
parameterize the contour bounding this
hypo cycloid by some parameters so that
i can actually integrate that contour
integral okay so we're gonna
parameterize and we're gonna
parameterize by some variable theta that
goes from 0 to 2pi
ok so we're essentially making some
mapping that is kind of like a circle so
X is going to equal a coast cubed of
theta y is going to equal a sine cubed
of theta and you can verify that if I
take the X to the 2/3 plus Y to the 2/3
then I get a to the 2/3 times Co squared
plus sine squared okay so this
parameterization satisfies this hypo
cycloid equation and we're going to
integrate from theta equals 0 to 2 pi so
you could code this up in MATLAB this is
actually a great exercise you should do
this I should have thought to do this
literally just in that lab make up
vector theta from zero to 2pi and
increments of 0.01 and plot this
x-coordinate versus this y-coordinates
and you will get this hypo cycloid and
you could even if you wanted to dot the
you could actually compute this contour
integral numerically in MATLAB and show
that it equals the area that we're going
to derive on paper ok so I would
recommend doing this in MATLAB you can
compute the area of this thing by doing
this this contour integral and I think
it's
kind of a good idea to do okay so from
Stokes's theorem what we have is the
let's call this the area is a then a is
gonna equal 1/2 of the integral around
the boundary of let's call it the
boundary of a of X dy minus y DX not too
bad ok this is I literally just wrote
down what we derive we use Stokes
theorem to get a formula for the area of
s we're integrating our nice curl equals
to vector field around this contour and
we get this expression this is my curl
equals to vector field and now what
we're going to do is we're going to
compute dy and DX so let's do that say
DX equals -3 a coast squared sign both
of theta d-theta okay tell me if I make
a mistake because this is easy to make a
mistake 3a sine squared theta cos theta
D theta
right that's DX and dy as a function of
D theta and now my integral around the
boundary is no longer an integral of dy
DX but it's an integral of D theta from
0 to 2pi so this is you know something
we all learned in like vector calculus
so this is equal to one-half of the
integral from 0 to 2 pi of X dy minus y
DX which is this nasty expression let's
see if I can do this ok X dy is 3 a
squared sine squared Coast to the fourth
of course f theta minus y DX so minus
minus is another plus 3a squared Coast
squared sine to the force times D theta
because both of these have a D theta
I want a little best but this is just x
times dy minus y times DX that's this so
now we've taken this nasty hypo cycloid
where I don't even know exactly how I
would do this integral over this surface
that'd be a nasty horrible integral
surface integral and I turned it into a
relatively innocuous contour integral
around this parametrized curve
parametrized by 0 to 2pi in theta and we
could go through all of the steps and
solve this and it's you know not
terribly illustrative to do I mean how
many of you want me to integrate this
sines and cosines it's a mess it's on my
notes and the answer is but it's not
hard all right it's it's relatively
straightforward these are all things we
know how to integrate and so the final
answer we end up getting something like
3/8 PI a squared okay and we can do that
by going from a nasty surface integral
to this relatively simpler contour
integral of the curl of my vector field
of my vector field that has curly cold
it to okay so kind of a simple example
this is the first major use of Stokes's
theorem not that simple of an example
okay so that's cute it's not that useful
it's kind of useful I'm sure you know at
some point you might find this useful
but there's a lot better uses for
Stokes's theorem Stokes theorem is
extremely useful in fluid mechanics and
an electro magnetics and in quantum
mechanics
special and general relativity so it's
really really useful in physics any
system where things rotate or have spin
or you know if you have a charge in a
magnetic field it does a helix right
that's the curl of that vector in fluid
mechanics if you have a piece of fluid
particle in a tornado it also has a
positive curl and so what Stokes's
theorem allows you to do is it allows
you to write the circulation inside of a
closed contour as a double integral of
the curl inside that closed contour lots
and lots of physics applications anytime
anything rotates you can use Stokes
theorem basically okay so pick your
favorite physics things rotate
electromagnetics fluid mechanics quantum
mechanics and so on but what's even I
think kind of more interesting so let's
say use two is physics with rotation
okay we're gonna look at this more in
fluid mechanics for example I'm sure
some of you have studied kelvins
circulation theorem something you use in
fluids in the Navy or Stokes equation so
if you want to figure out the power
output of a wind turbine or if you want
to think about the lift on a helicopter
you need to be thinking about total
circulation and use Stokes theorem to do
that we'll talk more about this later
but what I want to talk about right now
is use three which is this you can use
Stokes's theorem for physics without
rotation
okay so let's think about what what I
mean by this okay
so I have some vector field and we're
gonna draw this vector field V so that
it doesn't look like it has any curl
okay this doesn't really seem to have
any curl going on okay I could also draw
a vector field like the gravitational
potential that also doesn't have any
curl right everything just points in
towards the center of yours so what do
we know from Stokes's theorem Stokes's
theorem tells us that if I take some
arbitrary closed curve okay some
arbitrary closed curve partial s we know
that the integral over that boundary of
my closed curve this path integral
around my closed curve of my vector
field equals what
what does Stokes's theorem tell me that
this equals okay double integral I'm
gonna integrate over the entire area
enclosed by s of yeah good curl of F
let's just call it DX dy yes okay
now I told you that this vector field
had no curl so this has to equal zero
okay so this is I'm writing this in
green because this is called a
conservative vector field and what
conserving things that seems green so
what we have is if the curl of F equals
zero then this closed integral of F D s
always equals zero for all closed curves
partial s this is a huge this is called
then f is called a conservative vector
field
okay so if my vector field has no curl
if I have a fluid where nothing is
swirling there's no rotation there's no
vorticity if I have some electromagnetic
potential where if I drop a particle and
if that particle doesn't doesn't spin
around or anything if I have a vector
field V or F so that the curl is zero
everywhere then I can take the closed
path integral around any closed path
partial s of my vector field and it will
always equal zero okay these are an
incredibly important class of vector
fields called conservative vector fields
and they have huge properties so for
example the gravitational potential is a
conservative vector field and the
physical meaning of what it what it
means to be conservative is let's say I
draw earth
okay and let's say that I build the
world's largest most awesome roller
coaster this is gonna be pretty awesome
okay it's huge if there was no friction
in my system if all so this is that mass
on a wire right that we had on the
midterm and in the first half of the
class this is just my mass on a wire and
it satisfies some equation you know X
double dot equals what force equals mass
times acceleration so this equals minus
partial V partial X where V is my
conservative vector field this is my
conservative vector field and it always
points inward towards the earth so if I
think about the particle on a wire or
the roller coaster with no friction what
it means for to be a conservative vector
field is that I have the same energy at
every point along this curve
okay so if I start at the top of this
roller coaster Hill and I go down I'll
go through the whole track and I will
eventually come right back up to the top
with exactly the same amount of energy I
will have no energy gained or lost
integrating around this closed curve of
my conservative vector field okay so
conservative vector fields are huge
they're not just useful in gravitational
potentials they're also useful I mean
they're they are very very useful in
gravitational potentials we use the
conservative vector field approximation
any time we look at asteroids and comets
and spacecraft because there's very low
friction environments and they're in a
gravitational potential which is
conservative which is why Halley's Comet
comes back so repeatedly after the same
amount of years because it basically has
the same energy always and this is a
general statement of any vector field
that has zero curl
everywhere it is a conservative vector
field that's the same as our
gravitational potential are same as our
frictionless rollercoaster okay so there
are fluid analogies that have curl zero
they're like the frictionless roller
coaster if I start my fluid and I move
it to some other state and then I move
it back then there's no energy gained or
lost okay now let's go a little bit
deeper into this so I think that on
Monday after Thanksgiving I'm going to
tell you about potential flow fields
which is going to be another simple
example of a partial differential
equation that we actually are fully
equipped to solve right now and the
potential flow is so potential flow
theory is essentially a conservative
fluid system this is our one of our
oldest analogies for fluid dynamics it's
been used since the 1850s and all of the
early aircraft wings and aircraft bodies
were designed using potential flow
theory until about the 50s okay so this
conservative potential flow has a huge
amount of engineering at
vacation even though it's an
approximation of a real fluid system or
a real rollercoaster system you very
very useful approximation you can build
airplanes using these conservative
vector field approximations we'll talk
about that next next next Monday but
before we do I want to get a little
deeper into what are some properties of
these special vector fields that have no
curl okay I asked you on the homework to
prove two vector identities and I don't
remember exactly what they were what
were they okay I know I remember one of
them not the important one that if you
take the curl of the cross product of a
and B that it's orthogonal to both a and
B okay what was the other vector
identity the curl of the gradient is
equal yeah right so I think it is that
the curl of the gradient is equal to
zero is that right let's just
double-check pretty sure it's this right
I think it has to be okay
homework five now I asked you to show
that the divergence of the curl is equal
to zero okay well I didn't ask you to
solve the useful one anyway sorry about
that so you could also show that this is
definitely true the curl of the gradient
of some scalar potential is always equal
to zero this is actually really one of
the most important ones okay this is
extremely important to star important
okay you can prove that this is true so
if I had some scalar function fee then I
can get a vector function we can call
this my vector field is the gradient of
that scalar function partial V partial X
in the X Direction partial V partial Y
in the Y Direction partial V partial Z
in the Z direction you could write this
as you know F equals partial V partial X
partial V partial Y partial
fee partial Z you could also write this
as you know partial V partial X in the I
direction in the J direction and in the
K direction or if we were integrating
around a contour we would say DX D UI DZ
we'd be integrating in the DX dy and DZ
directions okay so what this tells me is
that if if my vector field F is the
gradient of some potential function fee
I'm calling it a potential function
because it satisfies this conservative
potential field kind of scenario if my
sector field is the curl of a potential
function then f is conservative because
the curl of F is equal to zero right the
curl of this F is definitely equal to
zero you can verify it
you know just using calculus and the
chain rule then if this F is the
gradient of some scalar function then F
is conservative
these are super super super special
vector fields so for example in the
particle on a bead example right we have
some mass on this bead on a wire then
the potential fee was the gravitational
potential which I guess was some you
know x squared minus X to the fourth or
something like that and so my grad fee
my vector field was just partial V
partial X which was 2x minus 4x cubed
and so I could drop a particle in that
vector field and I had X double dot
equals 2x minus 4x cubed I think there's
a minus minus but anyway I can derive
the equations for this bead on a wire
using this potential function and
because this really is because my vector
field really is the gradient of a scalar
potential that vector field has curl
zero and so it's conservative if I drop
this bead the event will go exactly to
the same height and then it'll come back
and go exactly to the same height over a
closed path energy is neither created
nor destroyed for these conservative
gradient systems ok extremely important
set of systems so what we want is we
want the curl of our vector field V
equals zero for it to be conservative
for energy to be conserved if our vector
field is the gradient of some scalar
potential then we're guaranteed to have
this zero curl and so this is guaranteed
to be a conservative vector field which
means that the closed integral over any
closed curve of F is equal to zero ok if
I have my earth here if I take and I
lift the mass and then I bring it back
down to the same height that I started
with then the integral of this closed
curve
to be equal to zero inside this
conservative vector field okay so a
couple things I haven't told you I
haven't really told you why energy is
conserved I've said that this is a
conservative vector field and what
conservative ation means is that the
integral of FDS equals zero I mean the
reason that energy is conserved is
because this potential function is
conserved and here potential really
means potential energy so if I take a
mass and I lift it up and then I bring
it back down then my potential energy is
the same as it was when I started that's
why we call these potential fields or
conservative fields conservation of
potential energy and so this idea of a
curl free vector field really
generalizes this basic fundamental
intuition that we have about you know
conservation of potential energy around
a closed curve okay we're going to talk
a lot more about this I think you should
take some time to really understand why
Stokes theorem is true code up the
example on the hypo cycloid and make
sure that you can plot it and actually
numerically add up F dotted in the
tangent direction in the D X D Y
Direction numerically calculate that
integral and make sure you get you know
8/3 PI a squared or whatever the answer
was and start thinking about these
conservative vector fields this is going
to be really really important later in
the class we're going to go deeper into
this okay have a great Thanksgiving I
will see you all in a few days eight or
so or seven or nine something all right